guess what happened over the week by
Bobby Lee got verified on Instagram
finally you did Bobby how does it happen
he begged his agent to do something very
tell so call your agent that's how you
do it I don't really know how they do it
but I don't know how they do it but Nick
Youssef my feature and Sarah Tiana who
were both my featured on the road we're
but verified before me and it really
hurt my feeling it really should because
I'm not joking you have the best
Instagram account I've ever seen thank
you so much you really really nice it's
coming from your mouth you really that
when you're verified right it makes it's
kind of more legitimate totally and to
see people that aren't had to have not
done nothing in their careers really
can't be verified before me oh my god it
really [ __ ] boy yeah cuz I was
telling him I know a soccer player who
plays in like the d-league in India who
would 4,000 would actually like a
thousand followers who go but then you
look I looked and like we man has a half
a million follower no not verified not
determined I wonder I don't know can I
tell you something guys me [ __ ] crazy
my girlfriend's verified and I'm not how
many followers on Twitter it drives her
crazy did she post more huh did she
tweet more probably it was more
followers yeah but she and she's also on
a TV show that's great what's his job
it's called teachers it's on TV land and
her and her girlfriend started it
together oh cool really cool you guys
start on it now yet oh yeah what the
[ __ ] that about - yeah let me ask you
this oh yes you have more followers in
you
yes she does how much more but not a lot
I only have 900 followers on Twitter and
well that's the problem
1,700 on Instagram yeah that's the
problem [ __ ] you yeah 900 followers yeah
man I'm Oliver shouldn't matter though
it's whether or not you George that's
right are you on Twitter
yeah but are you on Twitter how many
followers do you have
mm-hmm this guy Wow see this is called
you know this is calm you know what this
is called upward and downward social
comparison and this is what's [ __ ] up
our culture no I'm serious
you know how everybody's kind of
depressed right now yeah do you know
what I'm saying
yeah do you know I'm saying everybody's
kind of every things are kind of weird
right now and ever he's kind of
depressed
I think brexit has something to do with
that people just have this mood brexit
yeah but I'm not just talking about
right now my are the zeitgeist right now
of I'm not just talking about this week
or last week you know in general yeah
that's 5-10 years yes there's a thing
called upward social comparison and
downward social comparison and upward
social comparison is when you're looking
at [ __ ] all this [ __ ] that we're all
addicted to now Facebook Instagram
Twitter snapchat all this [ __ ] you get
it and you're looking and you're going
oh my god this person is such a cooler
life that means this person's killing it
and you're comparing yourself to that
and and we do it constantly now
constantly before you go to bed we're
doing it when you were first thing first
thing when I wake up what am i doing I'm
grab my phone scrolling through
everything and I'm see people and I got
this guy's doing better than me and I
compare myself and it so so we're all
doing that constantly now constantly
we're doing that and it's such it's
based on an unreality yes
not everybody curates their social media
based on how they want to appear not
really it's not true to their life and I
tell Burt this all the time he says well
you know your snaps are funny you're in
serious money I'm like I'm miserable
miserable eben says yes that that is a
zero reflection on the reality right
it's a greatest hit yeah yes
another thing somebody who said this is
so great
Facebook all the [ __ ] is the cocaine of
affirmation yeah it is that yes it's the
cocaine likes yes yes dopamine and
you're like oh yeah I'm doing good now
yeah and then but then it fades and then
you need it again and it's so anyway
upward social comparison is me looking
at you going
[ __ ] Bobby Lee's got how many fathers
got what and you know Jesus so see just
hearing that right now I go [ __ ] this
guy's got yeah but i but i go this guy's
got a [ __ ] hundred and thirty
thousand followers yeah like a [ __ ] I
have nine hundred and it makes me feel
like [ __ ] welcome you know he's more
popular but he's more famous that it and
I go down okay
but then I hear what's George here yeah
30 followers yeah that's called downward
social comparison and I go well at least
I'm not this [ __ ] guy but that
creates two kinds of monsters in you it
makes you both the insecure guy and the
guy who looks down at the guy with 30
followers so you're a double-headed
matenda it evens out so what's the
problem
it doesn't even know you look at other
people and you go oh my god I'm not Eric
stone know you feel shitty I'm even I
feel even then you look at DP and feel
ya because he hasn't well okay I have an
obsession of can we just make a
admission now so when we first started
this podcast I was used as a con he has
an obsession in particular don't see the
name okay we had with a particular Asian
comedian don't that's specific checks
his Instagram first thing in the morning
at 20 times during the day and last
thing before he goes to bed only his
mostly downward comparison I do download
compare but also a lot of what what if
this becomes me okay and then what
happens is he used me as a pawn in the
beginning a few episodes of our podcast
and I Unleashed you know a lot of like
why does this you know I basically like
no okay and we're making we're being
honest let's be honest be honest yeah
chris is here yeah the truth is the
but the truth is you have an obsession
with him it's not me and let's talk
about this type of obsession since we're
in the top reason why I'm obsessed with
this person is because he is down here
but he tries to make people believe that
he is not who he is and it drives me
crazy
so he does little lies he hashtags a lot
he likes his own photos you know I mean
the first guy to like his own photos he
does a lot of things you know me he'll
say hashtag his name
hashtag his name in plural hashtag his
name and friends self-importance yes
they're very self-important list
it drives me [ __ ] crazy what is that
that what is that well I can tell you
what he is what is he he's deeply
insecure and then he's deeply insecure
too because he's afraid he pits himself
against this guy as if they were in the
same racetrack bracket yeah so I say
before I was aging I thought before I
post anything I'll go to Klein go is
this does this feel like that guy
no why do we do that well do you have
that person in your life where you just
pitted against all the time but is that
person in comedy
yes sketch guy yes does he live in LA
yes say man you a company you wouldn't
you probably wouldn't you know and so
you have the same person in your life
I'm sure that you're pitted against kind
of yeah I think everyone has that
acceptive I think that's healthy in a
way yeah I think it's competitive I
right yeah I think it's healthy I make
up adversaries so it motivates me in my
head cuz this guy has no idea that I
feel the way I do the way I'm all 48 of
our episodes on this say his name Wow
obsessed you say his name we have yep I
love him in a way yeah I do love him in
a way I say he's on the Joker he's
Batman like we can't live without each
other even though he has no idea that I
have this
no idea he should be a guest on our show
I do won't do it he's no way you can do
it
I think you should look the man right in
the eye and say hey I check your
Instagram 87 times a day god you're wise
admission huh it might release you off
that burden of that weight that you feel
in your stomach when you wake up in the
morning give me a book I want what I
want to write it down upward what I
really want to look it up
well that's just upward mobility what's
it called
that's called upward social-comparison
up word Auto Show comparison and
downward social okay so if your
comparison hmm okay and down like I can
get that okay but a book you should read
it's called daring greatly daring
greatly by brené Brown why because it's
great what's it about [ __ ] text with all
the [ __ ] does
[Music]